so here's what we begin the probability
of a jackpot in any drawer is one
sixtieth okay by the way just as a side
note please avoid please avoid just
writing this all over the place okay
because in all kinds of questions and
this is a perfect example you're gonna
have to consider many different
probabilities and you want to be able to
distinguish them right so don't just
call them all paper probability it might
take you that extra 10 seconds to write
out something descriptive right but then
you can know what's going on and you
don't get mixed up in I've got five
different values for P and I don't know
which ones which okay so don't do that
this is the jack quietly Annie draw on
any given event okay so the first
question is what's it probably that the
jackpot prize would be one in each of
four consecutive draws okay so let's
think about this we've got in our tool
box these three basic ideas and they go
together in all different combinations
and gives every probability question
that exists actual simultaneous events
additional non simultaneous events and
the complement when you consider
somethings opposite okay now when you've
got a win in four consecutive draws
which one does this feel like to you
four consecutive draws now remember we
start off by having to think about how
you can illustrate this okay
so which of the tools listing sample
space assign of sample space a dot
diagram and a probability tree which
would be most helpful to you in this
situation
I think the tree diagram would be most
helpful okay because the sample space it
kind of already breaks down sorry that
salesmen keep saying dot diagram the DA
came already breaks down what you see
this you see that that means dot
diagrams out okay I'm listing by
extension right listing is worse it's
it's simpler than a dot diagram see like
if the dot diagrams are died then the
listing is probably also going to be
done so automatic me go now I'm what
kind of what kind of tree diagram do you
draw here's a bad tree dragged out to go
okay how many are the probabilities
sixty right so so sixty different I
could do this okay right so I could do
sixty different ranges and then I can
have what at the top all right okay and
that's that's a silly way to do it
obviously what would be a more efficient
way to construct a diagram that we
useful all I'm interested in is do I win
or do I not that's all okay so you could
say diagram yep mmm-hmm you could say we
don't lose right
that'd be fine okay but using a language
that we've developed already I think
it's smarter and more concise to say win
and not win that's all okay alright what
are the probabilities on it a 68 and 59
systems okay problem right now if I want
four consecutive wins okay
I'm already only interested in one of
the branches which one the top one okay
so I'm just gonna forget about this guy
for a second because he is no longer
useful to me and I say well this happens
and then I draw a game right we're not
with okay now think carefully what's the
probability now for these two branches
it's still 1 over 60 and 59 over 60 it's
still that and the question tells you
what's the key word that tells you any
draw good a single word tells you
there's no change here right so in a
real sense these two things these two
events are independent okay by the way
this is the under gamblers fallacy which
is like oh well if I you know say if
you're going down this way it's like I
lost and I lost it I lost I'm more
likely to win next time right because
I've lost so many times it's a lie you
look at the numbers every time it's
completely Brandi okay so your win once
or someone wins but you're in twice what
am I going to keep it okay at this point
you started to see the pattern okay
again I'm not interested in this I'm
going to branch off up here it's still
going to be the same right this is one
two three times you got into it one more
I'm not going to bother drawing it you
can see what's going on I need this and
this and this and the next one all
simultaneously right so what am I gonna
do I'm gonna multiply right so this will
be 1 over 60 to the power of 4 that's ok
I know what 6 cubed is but I don't know
what's it's the floor it's good someone
tell me whatever okay so in other words
not very likely but there you go
of course it's not very likely even even
one of them happening was not likely